boa tarde gente é eu sou filho de mãe
portuguesa com o pai brasileiro
eu sou ator chef de cozinha e
principalmente professor e amantes da
boa gastronomia é desde pequeno eu tive
ao lado da minha avó lado da minha mãe
cozinhando na beira do fogão minha casa
foi sempre cheia em sempre cheia muita
festa muito cheiro de comida
alguns de vocês já parou para pensar
qual o cheiro de comida vocês mais
gostam e por que eu vou dar 10 segundos
para vocês pensarem enquanto mexia
panela
beleza beleza beleza beleza e aí qual
chega você mais gosta
você então vamos lá você olha o café
bolo de cenoura azeite é exatamente
assim que funciona e tem cheiro que te
lembra alguém tem cheiro que te lembra
um lugar tem cheiro que te lembra a data
especial e assim a gente vai mantendo
isso é bom é foi mais ou menos aos dez
anos de idade
eu decidi que eu queria aprender a
cozinhar
então eu fui me envolvendo e enfiando
dentro da cozinha
então minha avó ia fazer um golo e eu
ficava do lado observando observando até
o dia que eu assumi as panelas e decidir
a partir desse dia que eu ia fazer
gastronomia
fiz faculdade de gastronomia
fui trabalhar e decidi que eu não queria
a cozinha que eu não queria chefiar uma
cozinha que eu queria ser professora que
eu queria ensinar que eu queria
transformar e só consegui eu só ia
conseguir isso através do conhecimento
bom meu primeiro emprego de professor
foi numa ong no parque novo mundo em são
paulo no meio da favela com 19 anos com
adolescentes em vulnerabilidade social
de 15 a 25 anos ou seja eu tinha aluno
que não sabia o que era comer que não
sabia o que era experimentar
eu tinha aluno de liberdade assistida
dentro da minha cozinha eu tinha
drogados
eu tinha dependentes de diversas
clínicas mas cada sorriso cada palavra
cada aprendizado e motivava a cada dia
mais minutinhos não vai ter mais gente
é cada dia mais me motivava a da aula e
aí eu só para vocês terem uma idéia eu
cheguei a dar aula com neném no colo a
minha aluna ficou grávida os nove meses
eu esperei ela voltar os quatro meses de
licença
no segundo mês ela voltou porque ela não
aguentava mais ficar sem aula de cozinha
e ela falou professor mas eu só tenho um
problema eu não posso deixar não tenho
com quem deixar o nenê é problema
resolvido
eu segurei nem de dois meses no braço e
escrevia no quadro branco com a outra
mão para que ela pudesse estudar para
que ela pudesse dar uma vida melhor do
que aquela teve para aquela criança eo
mais incrível de tudo isso é que a
criança chama caiu
foi incrível e eu só fiquei sabendo
quando ela voltou para a escola quando
ela voltou para a escola o professor eu
queria te falar uma coisa eu batizei meu
nome com seu filho
o meu filho com o seu nome
eu achei o máximo chorei passei por tudo
por todos os motivos
a ong fechou infelizmente por vários
processos burocráticos que a maioria de
nós conhece e eu fui dar uma faculdade
agora vou mudar o mundo vou sair dos
adolescentes novos adultos mentira eu
dava aula para o mesmo tipo de público e
aí eu aprendi na realidade eu quero
inclusão além do que eu já fazia eu
achava que inclusão era só o que eu
fazia tirar o pessoal da rua e botar o
pessoal da cozinha e botar o pessoal
para trabalhar
não eu aprendi inclusão de várias formas
eu aprendi inclusão de 12 e depois de
toda a experiência de vida desse dia os
a aposentadoria para fazer gastronomia
então eu tinha alunos se eu achava que
eu tinha alunos mais velhos na ong
agora tinha muito mais velhos que eu eu
formei uma aluna com 87 anos ela
aguentou os dois anos como todo aluno de
18 anos
nível eu tive aluno com deficiência
motora com praticamente zero
movimentação assim de pernas ea gente
adaptou uma cozinha inteira pra que essa
aluna pudesse ter aula cada sorriso da
aluna cada aprendizado da aluna era
importante pra gente na faculdade
hoje a faculdade que eu coordeno
seleciono
eu tenho dois alunos deficientes
auditivos
dentro da cozinha a gente tem um
intérprete dentro da cozinha e os meus
dois alunos despontam entre os melhores
alunos da minha turma
eu ensinei eles a verem a panela de
pressão o chiado da panela de pressão
com a mão
então eles sabiam que a panela de
pressão além do bico está girando pelo
conta da pressão que tinha na panela
é incrível é descomunal o acesso à
gastronomia eu acho que isso tende a
crescer mas hoje eu vim para cá pensando
uma coisa vocês já pararam para reparar
o quanto as nossas cozinhas diminuíram
as cozinhas das nossas casas diminuíram
será que os sentimentos também
diminuíram cozinha foi feita para ser
grande é perfeita mas te mesa grande
gente sentada em volta da mesa troca de
informação tá aí a cozinha é isso que a
gente tem de cozinha ea cozinha
assumindo cada dia mais a cada dia mais
ela desponta mais no mercado ela aparece
mais na televisão mas a cozinha de casa
sumiu
e aí eu volto na história do cheiro além
da lembrança do cheiro que a gente mais
gosta com a lembrança do pior cheiro que
vocês têm de cozinha
todo mundo tem chocolate queimada é
horrível realmente é tenebroso lei de
queimado o arroz arroz normal sem ser
arroz normal a quem mo queimado no geral
é ruim vão pôr assim mas eu por exemplo
dei uma mão e eu dei uma mão por conta
do cheiro de uma mão
eu como uma mão numa boa mas eu dei uma
moto quando o cheiro de uma mão
é isso que é isso que a gente chama de
gastronomia emocional de sensação
gustativa todos nós desde pequenas
nós vamos crescendo com memórias
olfativas e memórias gustativas do que a
gente gosta do que a gente não gosta e
isso vai influir isso vai influenciar no
cada vez mais a gente
bom só para aquele para a gente
finalizar
todo mundo falou o cheiro que mais
gostava que menos gostava
é o cheiro que eu mais gosto eo cheiro
que me influenciou a cada dia mais é
gostar de gastronomia querer aprender e
um cheiro que mexe comigo é o cheiro da
minha infância recheio de brigadeiro
não só eu também é eu escutei eu vim eu
só finge que não escutei gente muito
obrigado
ei